But I spoke with you a week or two ago about addressing parasites you recommended the product
perically. The instructions in the bottle say to take two capsules once a day after meals,
or someone who's loaded with parasites would it be helpful to take them twice a day that a motor
would have be harmful. Also, how many hours should I be using the right parasite frequencies daily?
or the one all clear is three hours long. So the parasite on the program, first of all,
you do it as often as you can. So I know you don't want to be sitting there doing a program
and taking up six hours of your day that you could be doing other things. But so you just have to use
balance and if you're going to sit and watch a movie, you're going to sit and read a book that by all
means run a program. You can't do it too often as the answer. As far as how you should take
the pair of clear, I've had people with loaded with parasites that I've had that took 12 or more a day
for a short period of time, every day for, you know, 12 to 15 a day for three months, but they were
taken 12 to 15 a day for a week or two to help knock this down and they dropped out for six a day.
Two a day, I don't think it's going to do it. So I thought I emailed you with dosage, I thought I
said four to six a day or something like that, I can't remember. But yeah, no, I've never
recommended hair clear just the dosage on the bottle. The dosage on the bottle is just for, you know,
but necessarily for trying to kill parasites, but try to maintain.